Hey everyone. Uh good morning. My name
is Rajan. Um and I'm going to be talking
about uh injecting security context
during wipe coding.
Um I'm a senior security engineer at
Dave. Uh it is a fintech company and my
focus areas mostly are on threat
modeling, secure by design, secure by
defaults. If you guys want to connect
with me, LinkedIn is the bless place. I
also do write a little bit about
security. Those are mostly my 2 a.m.
thoughts. So if you want to read those,
uh do subscribe.
What are we going to talk about? A
little bit about the problem. Uh what
exactly we are solving, my approach,
um how it works and why it works and
small walk through and then how you can
use it uh yourself.
But first, let me take you a year back
uh March 2025. Um how many guys have
seen this Twitter post? Pretty much.
Okay. Um this guy, he wipe coded an app
uh for a few days and then he shared a
lot about his app, but after I think a
week, he received some attacks uh and he
did not know what to do.
um and then he eventually has to shut
down his app.
So we are today in March 2026 and we're
still talking about uh wipe coding and
the challenges of uh security context
within the within the wipe coding.
I want to I want to also talk about how
we actually got here. Uh in the old days
we were probably using Stack Overflow to
copy paste a lot of code. Uh but these
days um we do a lot of prompt
engineering. Um the current workflow
that we follow right now is we see stuff
or probably think stuff uh we say or
prompt uh we click on accept all and
then we basically run stuff. The focus
these days is mostly around uh is my
code working rather than is my code
secure.
Due to this whole workflow, one of my
biggest fears is that one day my grandma
will call me and say that I have built
this new dog walking app. Can you please
use it? And I'm actually not ready for
that.
Now the challenge is um
in the appsac world um we know like all
of the vendors probably are shouting
that the developer to security ratio is
100 is to1. Um there are thousands of
issues that we have to deal with but the
main challenge is with the increase in
the code development
um we are we will only be able to catch
40% of the uh bugs or security flaws.
So uh can we what what exactly are we
missing in those 60% of the flaws? Um
these are basically when we don't really
have a deep understanding of our
security requirements. Um the accept all
culture leads to hidden bugs and
structural mess. Um there's a there's a
ton of code that has been written and we
don't know really why it has been
written. um AI also replicate insecure
patterns that are available from the
public repositories
and the fact that the code that is that
is generated seems plausible but it is
actually insecure code.
Now the challenge really is that why
can't we use the traditional methods of
you know security detection and
everything um
with within white coding as well. Well,
we can still use it, but the speed at
which the code is being developed is
really uh not up to the mark uh with
with VIP coding. Not only that, but uh
the design flaws they are basically not
going to be caught in the traditional uh
CI/CD scans.
Well, you can you can argue that we can
review we can threat model every
feature, every new endpoint, uh every
new system um and then
create new tickets, new prompts and then
feed them during web coding. But and
there are actually companies that are
working on this on automating this whole
workflow. But the challenge there is
accuracy. uh how accurately they can
detect what uh security context we need
and because of that it makes them
unscalable as well.
So the real question is can we wipe
securely given the constraints that the
current approach doesn't scale. It has
to match with the dev speed and it has
to be within the dev workflow. The apps
folks really care about developer not
leaving their workflows. So that is one
of the biggest constraints here.
One of the approaches that I have been
uh following is can we put the security
context within the code generation loop
itself. Uh what I mean by that is find
what the security context that is needed
and put it before when the code is being
written or the code is being generated
by our AI agents. Can we actually verify
uh the output uh immediately after the
generation and can we fix the fix that
code in line within while the intent or
the context is still fresh.
What I mean by that is we have the
context, generate the secure code with
that context, scan it right there and
patch it immediately.
The result for that is uh we have fewer
findings. We have faster fixes. There's
not a lot of rework would would be
needed both from the developers and from
the apps folks. Um and it is it is
within the dev workflow as well.
Now we talk a lot about context and we
all know about context engineering these
days but uh what really uh comprises a
security context for wipe coding. Now a
dev probably is working on a jet ticket
u maybe on a PR for a new change that is
a security context. Um, anything that is
specific to the feature that the dev is
working, any relevant best practices or
internal policies or standards or
compliance requirements. What I call
them is a security context back
and the the code that is generated is
constrained by that security context
back. What I mean by a security context
is like the data classification
policies. For example, let's say if if a
developer is working on a PCI
application where it has to deal with
card ID. Now your your compliance policy
says that uh we don't log that card ID
in the error messages. Now AI possibly
doesn't know all of this. U so that data
classification policies that is written
in the internal docs will come in handy
at the in the security context pack.
what I'm using uh to implement this is
uh MCP and I'm going to mention uh some
other uh possible um tools as well.
Uh the reason why I'm using MCP is uh it
is pretty standard protocol that is
being used by multiple different uh
coding agents. Um you can also enforce
permission and uh make it auditable as
well. Um it is composible. You can uh
plug and play with different uh uh APIs
like Jira, Confluence, your internal
policies, even your scanners like
security scanners uh as well.
It is also within the IDE which means
like it is within the dev workflow as
well. And one of the biggest thing I
like about MCP is basically context on
demand. If the context is properly
um written down,
it it will not it will not create
monolithic monolithic prompts.
>> Here's a highle workflow. Uh what
>> my tool will probably follow. So there's
a developer who is working on a task. It
provides the task requirements to the
agent. Um agent understands the scope,
the data flows and everything.
uh it calls the MCP for security review
which does the pre-coding analysis via
the MCP server. It identifies what are
the risk, what are the security
guidance, uh all the advices. Uh and
then it identify the security
requirements and put them into the
prompt which will be used for code
generation. Now the code now the agent
actually writes the code um with the
security context that has been provided.
Um we run some security scan uh see if
we have any vulnerabilities
uh if there are any vulnerabilities or
design flaws we fix them in line um and
they are applied immediately.
We reverify and then our code is
actually PR ready and then when our CS
scans kicks in there are actually no
issues. So this actually increases the
speed of the of the developer.
These are the general tools that I build
uh in my u in my project in case you
guys are interested. Here's the repo. Um
to keep the demo uh uh small uh I'll be
following three uh steps uh secure
coding workflow where we are doing uh a
lightweight security review before the
code is actually written. Uh we'll write
the code. We'll not write but the agent
will write. Um and then we'll actually
run uh verify code security which will
try to verify all the requirements that
are identified in step one.
For the demo purposes I'm using a um
open-source MCB observability tool OTO.
Um I'm not associated with it anyways.
Uh but I like the tool. So I cloned it.
I use it and I wanted to implement
something that is based on my
requirement.
Um so I asked the coding agent to give
me to to build a web hook receiver
endpoint that will that will accept any
incoming web hook from external services
like GitHub or Slack and that triggers
uh some other agent agentic workflow
executions. I also asked him just to
simplify uh where to add all of this um
and then the new route and just to try
to be very specific.
Now I did it in uh two flow. So once I
disabled my tools and try to generate
the code and do a security review.
During that security review uh you can
see that there are
um two issues that are identified uh
which were after the code has been
generated. So header forwarding
sensitive header header forwarding leak
sensitive data and then authorization
tokens that are being passed around in
the entire workflow.
I'm sorry.
Um but once I enable my tools uh and
perform a security review before the
code is being written um you can see in
the screenshot um it tells you what the
what the task is which is basically uh
the requirement uh what technologies uh
it is using so that it can pull in
relevant security context relevant to go
kubernetes and rest apis. Um it
specifically mentions to include the
guidelines and then include prompt
injection which is which means that
whatever the security guidelines are
include that into inject them in into
the prompt that is being used for the
code generation.
After the pre-coding analysis, it
identified that this is a high-risk uh
uh requirement uh and with the key CA
categories as API security, data
validation and some web security uh uh
requirement. So it pulls in all the
guidelines related to those uh
categories and and you you can see that
the key takeaways to build into the code
from the start are validating all inputs
filtering out sensitive headers that
were actually a finding if we have not
done this
proper and handling body size limits and
following uh least privilege.
Step two is pretty simple. Based on all
the requirements, the agent actually
generates uh uh generates the code with
the security guidance and it actually
has header block list baked into baked
into from the start.
Once the code is generated, we actually
perform another code analysis
um where you can see uh it passes passes
in the uh the code whatever the file
path is and the security context u based
on the the the analysis that we did in
step one. It passes all of those
guidance and verifies if the code
actually matches all of these best
practices.
Now there one of the major advantage of
this is basically the feedback is
immediate when the context and the
requirement the developer requirement is
still fresh still in the chat window and
it is not somewhere in the CI uh
pipeline.
Um this is the thought process of
cursor. I know it is a little bit later
um but if you can see it performs a
security review no hardcoded password no
SQL queries pass pass pass pass pass
pass pass pass pass pass pass pass pass
uh at the bottom you can see the last
line it says no critical or high
severity issues found and uh the
implementation aligns well with security
review guidance
uh okay this is a much better view um
it's basically gives gives you a table
format uh and saying that all the uh
checklist items are basically passing
and there are no critical high or medium
security issues. Now um
just to reiterate the what the workflow
was uh we ran a lightweight security
review initially before the code
generation um it returned high risk uh
flagged all the security guidelines that
we need to pull in. uh it generates the
code with proper security guidance like
uh header block list authorization
cookies u x forwarded for header and xre
ips that are built in from line one um
and other stuff as well and then it
actually verifies if the code that is
being generated align with the security
guidance that was provided in step one.
Well, um you might think like this is so
easy, but it isn't. Uh the security
guidelines that work for humans does not
work very well with uh with our AI.
So, couple of things to notice here is
um we have all the security guidelines
uh available right there uh within the
context at the time of generation. These
are some of the OASP uh cheat sheet and
best practices that I have put into the
tool itself. Um you can also u add your
own or pull in directly from Confluence
for example or some other Google docs.
Another key thing is uh intelligent
filtering while labels to prevent
context blo. um all all of these uh
guidelines they have a proper category
uh so that the AI agent can actually
filter it out pretty clearly and uh what
where exactly it needs to identify all
of these. So for for example if you're
talking about authentication
um and you're building or you're working
towards JWT um it will actually pull in
this uh guide. So remember if you're uh
using this and using your own internal
standards or guidelines uh make sure to
add these three uh tags.
Yeah. So if you want to make it your uh
if you want to use it internally, you
can also inject your own threat models
here. Um you can have your own internal
uh secure coding guidelines uh your
golden paths. what you think are the
best practices or any approved
libraries. Um, SCA is like a big thing
with white coding. And then you can also
define what uh is the definition of done
in this.
Uh where it helps um it helps in uh
repetitive work and identifying known
patterns. um it can identify common uh
vulnerabilities very early. So the
developer don't have to wait for the CI
scans to to to uh trigger.
However, it doesn't replace uh any
threat modeling that is uh being done
for the new systems. You should
absolutely do it and uh for big systems
or big changes, you absolutely do a
human review as well.
Cool. Um finally um I believe that pipe
coding uh fails when the context is
missing. We will always have some some
flaw uh if we do not provide the correct
context. Um the way to solve is uh we
can inject security requirements right
before the code is generated.
We can also verify and patch immediately
after the code is generated. So that
that would remove a lot of developer
time and that is one way to for security
to match the speed of developers
and
use MCP for uh providing the context.
You can also use hooks uh which makes um
all of these tools calling very
deterministic.
uh however tools uh hooks are not
supported by all the IDEs and it's only
by claude and cursor.
It also MCP also makes it audible as
well. So uh that's why I chose MCP
and that's it. Thank you.
I got a first question. Do you think
this will be initially or sorry
eventually just adapted in as a skill
like when I make a request I'm like hey
I'm doing a feature here's what the
feature looks like blah blah blah prompt
do you think they'll just be a sub agent
skill automatically very quickly here to
do this
>> you you can make it a skill but for big
organizations like how much how much of
the context within the scale are you
going to put in plus are you going to
put in to every repo let's say an
organization has thousand repos so you
would have to put in uh the scale
requirements into thousand repos. So you
need a centralized place uh where you I
can actually pull in all of this context
plus the changes that you make if you're
putting it into the skills you would now
have to make into thousand repos which
doesn't which makes it non-scalable.
>> Perfect.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh does anyone have a question?
>> Perfect. I'm coming to you.
>> Thank you. Thank you. It was a great
talk. Um my question is about when does
this trigger like security review
trigger? Would it trigger when code is
committed to the code repository or
before that during the ID?
>> It's it's within the ID.
>> Within the ID.
>> Yeah, at when the code is being
generated.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> Yeah, awesome talk. Thanks. So, how do
you make sure that this actually
happens?
Right. Um like do you have telemetry
about how often developers are doing
things and then how often they're
calling the tool and like cross compare
or you mentioned hooks earlier. I know
you can use those to just gather
information like when people submit
prompts and things like that but like
and like how do you even encourage the
local IDEs to call the MCP server.
>> Yeah. So a lot of it depends upon your
tool description. Um so you have to make
the tool description of uh your MCPS uh
so that in such a way that the uh your
agent actually calls them. Um that is
one of the functionalities of MCPS that
you know you can you you can make it
call every time but um it it's I would
say it's not 100% time and that's why
you can use hooks uh to make it
deterministic. So with hooks you can
actually call it like every time.
>> We got time for one more.
>> Hi. Um have you measured how well it's
working? Like what residual security
bugs are found after using this process?
Yeah, it definitely helps in a lot of
sorry
it definitely helps in a lot of uh
business logic issues uh compared to the
things that are not identified with the
security scanners. So it has been very
helpful there. Plus um like I mentioned
developers work on geo digits. So they
don't have to come to us. Uh if we
provide them certain guidance and if
they're using uh this tool the agent
automatically pulls all the
requirements. So that has been one of
the advantage as well. And depending
upon uh the tool description it calls in
the security review and the code
verifier as well.
Perfect. Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.